siete pronti bene io no
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video io sono famigerati e su silvio si
sia bon action 3 ok c'è io da adesso in
avanti dato che rim pronunciabile
chiamerò semplicemente cat mario due in
poche parole sarebbe il sequel di quel
tranquillissimo e bellissimo gioco
chiamato jet mario che ho finito per
grazia di dio circa una settimana fa
perché dato che mi volete un bene
dell'anima avete detto fa vj visto che
ti è piaciuto tanto cat mario perché non
provi se quello vero sì ovvio nation e
allora io ho detto ma perché non farlo
dai tanto gioco tranquillo allora direi
di inizia perfetto già perso nel menù
non ho neanche iniziato allora vabbè
presenta perfetto vai
partiamo con due vite ok sembra molto
simile che questa parte sembra
abbastanza facile evidentemente no ok
allora piano piano piano ne niente
allora ragazzi creste per chi non
conosceva cat mario come potete vedere
un gioco molto tranquillo devo riuscire
a superare sto cazzo di punto ma porca
[ __ ] siamo all'inizio maledizione
all'inizio all inizio porca [ __ ] ok
ma che casa c'era io passi può cioè non
ho neanche iniziato allora facciamo ok
il primo passo abbiamo fatto allora devo
riuscire se ce l'ho fatta
ok la gara adesso con moltissima calma
possiamo proseguire
devo aspettarmi ogni cosa raga lo so lo
so già in anticipo c'è una cosa ok
cioè
devo farci l'abitudine perché sarà tutto
così non mi sono ricordato maledizione
porca [ __ ] dobbiamo riuscire a fare
sto pezzo senza superare allora
l'abbiamo capito che si fa così ok la
donna che culo che è cool assurdo ok
allora devo stare lontano da qui sotto
perfetto vai vai vai se no
buongiorno quasi fatta ma l'edizione
ragazze mi son dimenticato un perfetto
ci stavo finendo secco ci sono finito
per chi non ha visto che mario quello
normale sappia che se c'è qualcuno a cui
danno fastidio le parolacce o parole
scomode generale diciamo che in questa
serie non fa per lui quindi meglio che
la evitiate a prescindere proprio però
vabbè continuiamo freddo e mi capire che
cosa devo fare
prima di far casignano nascendo qui
sotto no porca [ __ ] four cortona ci
sarei arrivato subito c'è ma che cazzo
allora non prendiamoci per il culo
perché non è normale sta cosa
anche senza le trappole c'è mamma non si
può maledizione ole ole ce l'abbiamo
fatta
cazzo oddio no no no no come si fa come
si fa come sì ma come si fa come si fa
come sai vota aiutò cazzo come dovrei
fare scusami non so le ali ok ragazzi
sono devo riuscire a saltare nell'altra
sponda se ce l'ho fatta
ok raga devo riuscire a trovare una
bandiera il prima possibile
niente
niente niente niente ok ok ok perfetto
piano adesso molto piano molto piano se
c'entra un pochino di scribblenauts
perfetto raga ritorno ed evo devo
prenderlo per forza perché non ok io lo
sapevo ovviamente porca [ __ ]
c'è ma fatemi capire allora no ok no
giorna non ci posso raga non lo credo
non ci voglio credere
non ci voglio credere cioè io ho il muro
che vola al monitor prima dati nella
puntata non ce la faccio no no ma no ma
no ma no ma no
raga non coincidono no no no no no
ragano non si può fare è una presa per
il culo questo non è jackett mario alla
lunga se no niente dopo niente allora
noi dobbiamo chiarirci su una cosa non
dovete consigliarmi steve jobs perché
poi me la devo giocare io me la devo
giocare io ok no non mi fate incazzare
c'è una bandiera l'isi vero c'è una
bandiera c'è una bandiera ma non ci
arrivo alla bandiera perché sono un
cazzo di idiota non ci arrivo la
bongiorno iniziale non ci arrivo porca
[ __ ]
cioè non ce la posso fare raga non ci
riesco perché nicosia testi giochi cazzo
è peggio di quello di prima e grigi
ticket mario nel packet mario non è un
cazzo in confronto veramente c'è ma vi
giuro è una cosa incredibile questo è
peggio ok maledizione
siete
vai così vieni a prendermi tanto che
cosa cazzo me ne fotte cio la bandiera
[ __ ] ce l'ho fatta raga dopo un ora
siamo alla prima bandiera c'è ci ho
messo un secolo è stato bene ma che
cazzo sono sì ok ce l'ho fatta
incredibile allora vediamo di capirci ma
anche il cazzo ester no no no no no no
merda meno male che c'è la bandiera e
riparto da lì perfetto allora raga
capiamoci un secondo cosa devo fare qui
devo aspettare che passi la mandria
perfetto allora rag andiamo pianissimo
devo andare di sotto penso perché
personale che cosa cazzo con i basat
straiati vale detto non ci credo non ci
non ci voglio credere
mi si è spento il gioco devo iniziarmi
tutto no no no no non mi guardare così
no mi guardare così io non lo rifaccio
io non lo rifaccio no no no
assolutamente no di quella [ __ ] di
quella [ __ ] di quella [ __ ]
raga non ci voglio credere non ci voi
non ci voglio credere veramente non ci
voglio grade ok basta mi sono rotto il
cazzo adesso lo faccio tutto quanto
senza morire neanche una volta
vai così quando sono deciso solo lecciso
non mi ferma più nessuno [ __ ]
tutto ok
vai così ho passato tipo 2 ore per
tornare al punto di prima
mai così vai così no no no no set
perfetto vai non muoio neanche una volta
mi sono rotto il cazzo
vai cos'è
se c'è o mio dio mio dio mio dio che
cura ce l'ho fatta non ci credo ho mai
così non me ne frega un cazzo
adesso tutto filato senza neanche
perdere tempo vai così vai così
maledizione lo finisco tutto così vai
col perfetto massacro terminator son
diventato vai così vai sono le ruote non
ci sono più
che culo che cuba bastardo di merda top
reso peccati presto stronzo ce l'ho
fatta non ci posso credere che ci sono
troppe lo.ve bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
sea [ __ ] pure a te raga ci sono ci
sono trappole ovunque na cosa
impressiona anche qui anche qui lo so
che c'era da tanto lo so so per certo
anche questa ma che cazzo era ok bene
l'ho superato
non ci credo non ci posso credere è
stato ok ragazzo na arrivato alla fine
c'è la scalinata finale poi c'è la
bandiera allora io raga tanto lo so lo
so che c'è una trappola non lo so ed io
piango già prima io vado ma tanto lo so
giace non hanno nel senso ma guardate la
guarda vedete e mancava tanto così dalla
bandiera tanto così mi mancava tanto
così per finire livello e perché secondo
voi non l'ho finito ve lo dico io perché
sono un idiota di me vabbè raga io direi
di chiudere qui veramente
ora che non ce la faccio più non so
quanto è durato il video tra tagli e
tutto ma vi giuro
ve lo assicuro che questo in confronto
al primo kit mario c'è primo che marin
confronto veramente era soltanto un
riscaldamento tra virgolette c'è questo
è veramente impensabile è impossibile da
fare se no veramente raga io vi giuro
sono non ce la faccio più
indipendentemente da quando è uscito
lungo il video vi giuro è che siamo
soltanto il primo livello mio dio c'è ma
veramente raga ma questo è soltanto il
primo ma gli altri livelli come cazzo
sono allora raga fatemi sapere se volete
che io continui questa seria perché
ovviamente non sono obbligato a farlo se
non mi piace
vabbè fatemi sapere io se se vedo che ai
video prende tanti mi piace che quindi
come se gliela apprezzate la continuo
non so che cosa può succedere nei
prossimi episodi maledizione vabbè raga
io io vi giuro non ce la sto facendo più
io la chiudo qui e se vi dove è piaciuto
lasciate un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook come non divido
trovate nella descrizione se non siete
ancora iscritti iscrivetevi noi ci
vediamo al prossimo video bella ragazzi